it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
the whole
world is gone crazy a little bit dude
john craig's doing a little diet dr
pepper little i was gonna say dc but
this is dp though so i think i'm being
do you know here's a trivia question i
think i'm right about this what the
secret ingredient in dr pepper is with
prunes right yeah prune juice
being a dp you want me mark deepy uh
if i had to choose
no see that
get younger though right because dp be
you don't have to choose you can yeah
best of both worlds well i don't know if
i had a choice between any two guys oh
well it would be between me mark or mark
and chin or me and chad
the whole thing's gonna mix it up little
asian in there i know chin i feel like
is like he's my he's the only decent
person in this room yeah so chin would
be like abused though yeah you're not
going to break your chin the whole time
be like is this all right i mean are you
okay are you comfortable yeah totally me
can you still talk yeah and i'd be like
all right yeah you know i'd be like all
right well let's just get it over with
yeah and then you'd be giggling the
whole time oh percent
hey brandon seriously yeah you know it's
stuff brian wednesday it's stuff brian
wednesday
it's it's it's it's spit roast wednesday
that's what we call it spit roasting i
see you're talking about something
different i'm talking about
me and big ass mark behind you deep in
and hold on hold on chin's in the front
hold on that's not spitballing two dicks
in my romper yeah dp dude so you guys
are going to push your dicks together
well our balls you're gonna die yeah no
your dick's gonna touch bro no no no no
no
no hey dude i don't know what that's
called both in you you just said it no
no won the oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that's interesting that's what's
happening yeah it's called double down
you and mark are going to have your
balls and your dongs touching super hard
and very hard but it's not gay if you're
inside a bottle
it's not gay if you're inside another
man's a friend of yours it's the rules
anybody's bundle um mud whistle yeah all
right straight up stop brian wednesday
yeah i need poppers for my nose because
i got a dilate
gotta have some poppers for your nose
well you know what can we we're adults
can we not go right to i don't know how
we're gonna start saying [ __ ] well
something you talked about before how
about this can we talk about just for
once in the 10 years one thing of
substance just one
can anybody have anything of substance
to talk about watch that watch the
silence in the room
yeah
it's amazing i mean beverly hills tried
doing the mass man do you see how that
went
ah
the fans were the the people that lived
in it oh i don't think so yeah okay well
i think i think it's funny
kamala harris said my pronouns are she
she her and most people are like look
that's fine but america is
like americans have a lot of other [ __ ]
on their mind a lot of people
inflation price of gas price of food
there's a lot of other [ __ ] and so when
you make that
sort of front and center we kind of go
you feel out of touch
you just feel out of focus yeah but also
it's not about pronouns but unless your
pronouns are something like
that we're not aware of you we know we
know you're she hurt can you imagine if
i held a press conference like all right
everybody gather around
pronouns are he him yeah but here's how
i look at it and this guy was i read
this really good article about us he's
like 24 he works for writes for new
yorker magazine smart guy and he's
non-binary and he's a journalist but
he's 24 but he's [ __ ] smart and
finally he basically said the problem
with coming out as non-binary was that i
everybody then goes like this they go oh
that's the guy or the person that okay
that's they and you get put over there
and you're just as calcified as he him
it becomes
your identity
and so finally he was like he ends the
article with like look just i'm done
with the [ __ ] just call me by my name
just call me by my name yeah that's what
happens
because it's a little bit like you know
it's a little bit like that maybe i said
this before if i walked around if i
walked in with a sword
and you said brian what's with the swag
self-defense and you go
all right okay well that's what he does
you know that's what he wants to do i
wouldn't care as long as you were like
swinging it around it's just that i
become the guy with the sword yeah i'm
the guy over there
even if i'm carrying a gun
like i know it's your constitutional
right to get my gun but if i'm walking
around all the time with a gun in a way
when i walk in the room i'm the guy with
the gun like if we're at the beach and i
i'm like i gotta just you know i keep my
shirt long because i got my bro we're
like
he's he's he comes with his gun it's
weird
your gun boy you become gunman i didn't
tell you in in san diego the man i think
it's late show saturday you know it's
chaos out there and she comes back she's
like we have a bit she's a new manager
why they're bringing the issue to me i
have no clue she goes uh we have a bit
of an issue so there's a gentleman uh
who wants to come in huge fan about vip
he's buying merch um but he has his uh
concealed to carry uh gun on him i go oh
it's like a like a nine millimeter she's
like
big gun and i go and he's trying to come
into the comic club she was yeah
what'd you do she was well he's like
arguing it's his right and he has the
license and all that you go
to be fair it is like you know what do
you what do you want me to do she goes i
because you mean the comedy club i'm
like
i don't know but i don't make the rules
so yeah you're gonna tell gun boy to
[ __ ] turn away and so then she called
like the head of laugh factory he's like
he can't bring a gun in the comedy show
dude yeah if you want in he's like you
know you're gonna you can just
drop up your car and come back in the
car and they told me i'm like oh man
this guy's gonna put up a [ __ ] fuss
yeah and he went okay
right just like yeah i'll just go drop
it off and come right back okay yeah
yeah
but and then there you go it's a big
enough gun i i have you ever worn a big
enough gun it's a lot i've never worn
one no it's not heavy but also like they
were like like dude who we don't need in
comedy clubs like
craig robinson just had a shooting that
is and like i'm not opposed i know what
you're saying yeah i know what you're
saying but i was like can you ask him if
he has any like uh experience with
shooting that thing yeah before he just
i hope you have a lot of training yeah
or like some you know military
background please something cause
because when i'm at terran tactical and
i have a gun that glock 17 which i own
that's a big piece of metal
no
it's big it's if you're you're wearing a
shirt over it you're going to see the
gun your gun boy your gun boy your game
boy you're going to be a gun boy there
is there is a holster where you can you
wear it literally down your pants and
then you you pull this flap up and you
just put you go shoot and then you got
your gun but this a lot that's a lot of
work it's a lot of work do you have a
holster are you trying not to get chicks
off holster yeah
you can't wear like dope clothes so you
have a holster and have like a popping
outfit it's a there it is it's a good
idea maybe but it's like this i should
probably have a lot of water i should
probably have a hundred gallons of water
and a hundred pounds of rice and a a
freezer full of meat in case the
apocalypse hits but i don't it was it
the leather one yeah
it's a lot what's in the satchel oh
that's my gun that's some gun holder
yeah
well my favorite part is they they're
everyone's so stressed out that the guy
was going to put up a fight and he goes
yeah no problem
all right yeah problem stop all right
we'll drop back up we'll be right back
she's gonna watch some comedy i don't
know if you need a gun this you know
yeah they were like so did he tell them
yeah is he telling me oh yeah i'll talk
about your stage you guys know i can see
a license here i'm bringing the show and
they're like no you're not he's like
well it is uh yeah am i right and i do
have the license so she does yep that's
him that's what i told him i mean if he
has license he seems normal
constitutional right yeah i was like you
know is he sweating or is he like
shaking you know but that's the other
problem is that you know it's all good
you can carry a gun i understand
it's just that you are going to get to
places where they go we can't you know
it's just like comic con
but also the people around here are
in this climate right now especially you
know it's not like in california there's
not a ton of people carrying guns right
you're just going to sit there the
comment show just
everyone's
you think everyone's like yeah what's up
dude no you're going to be stressed as
[ __ ] you're ar 15. yeah he's just
sitting there
he's like
i think it has to be concealed
that makes sense
well no in this state oh right so in
other states i think your your concealed
weapons permit your cwp
is
you have to have it yeah you can't have
it like next to your quesadilla yeah
it's a little bit like in san francisco
you can walk around with your dick out
can't be hard
interesting because the gus picks up
like yeah not allowed to have a hard
dick in public but you can have your
dick out as long as it's flat how scared
would it be if they let that guy own
that gun and he was just out of his mind
like i was telling joke he's like chop
chop like dude you're killing me
he's like waving
just shooting the gun in the air oh
they're all like hey man just out of his
[ __ ] mind that scares me also
hilarious guns scare me oh me too
whenever i see one like oh my god
ruin my own i'm holding them like dear
god rogan and i went to a party we were
both like 28 years old went some party
in the hollywood hills and i'll never
forget
he didn't see it
but a kid was walking so we were all in
this traffic jam because of the valet we
were trying to leave we're trying to get
out of the party and there was just a
[ __ ] because you know the hills they
have all those like really narrow roads
so we're all stuck nobody can go and go
anywhere
and joe is driving
and
i see a sort of what looks like sort of
a
you know kind of a gang gang banger kid
kid
uh clearly white kid yeah
he was actually latin i think he was
mexican or something other than white
yeah you say gang banger yeah i don't
banger i don't see color no you don't
but he
pulled the gun out he pulled an uh he
pulled a nine millimeter out of his
waistband yep and then
turned it looked at it and put it back
in his waistband
and i said to joe i go
and we were trapped in that [ __ ] car
and i remember just i real i was like
we can't do a thing if that guy turns
and shoots at us there's nothing you can
do and i said to you i go like that
guy's gonna he's where i go that guy
right there just pulled out a gun
i remember he said [ __ ] he goes it's
just like we're sitting ducks we're
flesh and bone you're behind flesh and
bone yeah you get behind the car though
you know
well no we were in the car and there's
nowhere to go right you're in the car
he's right there yeah you wouldn't have
time he took duck trying to go backpack
oh she's that close yeah you're sitting
there again we're standing in the
parking garage
see a homeless dude but he has like this
long like trench coat on
no shoes
and we're pulling in and like he was
like stay in the spot and he moves over
that makes up pulls out
mark and my brother uh tracked it mark
and uh
trey didn't really see what's going on
he pulls out i don't mean like a
small knife i mean this thing was like
this we
he was on we're on the third flight and
when we're going the same floor i see
people walking in
wait someone
we're just talking to pretend [ __ ]
blade over there the the homeless blade
is just getting so dangerous oh and i
was like but there's kids comic con but
it was during the day so the p there's
kids there's everyone around there so i
found scared like dude you know i'm not
trying to freak everybody out so
there's a homeless guy there and i don't
mean he has i know if you go out and be
careful dude i don't even have like a
small knife i'm talking here's a [ __ ]
machete cut your head off i was like get
rid i was like but and he was walking
out of the structure the opposite way i
said there's so many families coming
here i would go around the back man you
got to get them from behind
and restrain them and pull them down to
the cops they found themselves in the
face
i made that up but i don't know how the
story ends
i think the cop went no problem thank
you that guy's got to get arrested
right now like you can't let somebody
like that you gotta take the knife
regardless yes you do
hey b right now and i'm this is a good
thing a lot of people are talking about
their mental health dude and there's a
lot of ways you can take care of it your
brain is the engine for your body better
help
online therapy you can find an online
therapist in less than 48 hours a
licensed therapist you have to be in a
waiting room you don't have to go
through all that regularly you can
actually connect to somebody by phone
you can do it by uh facetime you can do
all kinds of stuff but it is help is
there and it's online and it's real and
it's very very good it's important and
it's also a lot more affordable than
in-person therapy so try it out right
now and the listening and viewers of the
500 kid you get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
fighter that's better h-e-l-p dot com
fighter hey b i'll tell you right now
man i don't like waiting on a paycheck
when the bills are due daddy wanted a
couple days early you got bills due
chime oh my god i'm glad chime is on
board man what are you waiting for
hopefully not your paycheck get started
with chime today applying for a free
account takes less than two minutes get
started chime dot com slash fighter
that's chimed.com
fighter all right we got you man it's
got an award-winning mobile app it makes
it very easy
you're not your paycheck okay you can
get started with chime you can get a
paycheck up to two days early that's
chime.com
spider bank and services and debt card
provided by the bank corp uh or stride
bank n a members fdic early access to
direct deposit funds depends on payer
had to say that had to say that either
way you get a free account takes less
than two minutes
you asked for something serious earlier
yeah of substance
turns out
after a review of studies over the
course of decades
depression is not caused by low
serotonin levels and therefore tom
cruise is vindicated
yeah about this stuff like he said tom
cruise
back remember when he went on that rant
that like it was like oh my god he's
crazy not that one with matt lauer when
he goes and actually what's funny is oh
yeah you if you listen to it now they
took this part out of
the the the clip he references ritalin
and adderall and he says we shouldn't
have kids on ritalin and adderall
and then
uh matt laura goes well it works for
some people and he goes no no you're not
listening to me
he was right about it something i said
yeah
and they made him look stupid but
after all this study they go yeah
depression isn't caused by low serotonin
in the blood there's no way to measure
it or you know
so what's it caused by they still don't
know they know that well for example the
reason psilocybin and
antidepressants both work
is that they create new neurons
antidepressants take longer that's why
some people get more depressed
because increasing your serotonin can
block certain things that feel good like
from dopamine so it's like i used to you
know i used to get high now i'm taking
these anti-depressants and they block me
from feeling good temporarily from this
thing
right like you're just people that tell
me i've never used them but they tell me
it's like life is just kind of gray
there's no black there's no there's no
highs there's no lows it's just in the
middle because your favorite thing was
drinking coffee in the morning that was
like you'd wake up like oh thank god now
you're just like you have a serotonin
serotonin interferes you like the
excitement feeling you get of like
what's a dopamine rush you know like
looking for something new exciting
you're really activated and aware
serotonin can kind of interfere with
that process i guess so if you up this
before the new neurons get created
you're kind of in almost a pleasure
deficit so how so how's this help it
just means what well it means that they
don't know how some they know that a lot
of serotonin uptake inhibitors
don't they don't know how they work and
they know they work for some people and
don't work at all for other people yeah
and then they know that sometimes they
can give people they can get people like
prozac can get people actually change
your personality and they it can
actually help you
like so it it
helps for like anorexia patients and
things for whatever reason sometimes and
then there then sometimes if you're
bipolar and you take an antidepressant
serotonin uptake inhibitor it can it can
lead to suicide right so it's all over
the place right yeah they don't know a
lot yeah and i guess the
real statement is
the model of chemical imbalance in your
brain is sort of debunked by this
and that's what tom cruise is saying
back he's like i always wondered how
they measure chemicals that's what he's
saying he's like you can't you can't go
oh your serotonin is low we're going to
give you this much okay well if
somebody's lower than the other do you
get more what it's totally imprecise
and it also paints this really
simplistic picture of depression where
johann hari was a jre guest he talked
about it's like you need community you
need purpose you need all these other
things to get you know to like feel good
about just brain chemicals yeah
interesting so you need to do [ __ ] tom
cruise in that interview bro he was such
a boss
because you're not listening what i'm
saying you don't know the way the human
brain works i do yeah
they framed it
i say whatever you want about him that
dude has been at the top of the game and
his game
yeah he's 60 and still crushing it it's
impressive to re-listen to the interview
for able to because oh my god out of
context tom cruise makes over a hundred
million dollars off the new top gun
because he's like a producer i'm sure he
had back in on it oh my god but even i
was shocked about this because joaquin
phoenix who he only he's making 20
million for the next joker but the
original joker made over a billion
dollars so that's kind of like whoa
salary i'd assume yeah that's how much
yeah but i'm still like
because jim carrey used to have those
deals where it's like you're not getting
net because i can always [ __ ] with you
counting he gets gross it's like 20
million plus
five percent of the every ticket that
comes in off the table
that's how uh todd phillips who did uh
joker right
he came to fame because he was the first
one in hollywood
because they didn't want to pass those
bro movies you know like to hang over an
old school brand's a mold of them uh
they want to pass both of those so todd
phillips goes cool cool cool just give
us the the funding we'll cover it here's
this i'll even cover all of it and then
but we want a bigger back end off ticket
sales in the movie theaters and
hollywood whatever studio it was
universal or uh paramount went
yes this movie's gonna eat dick we'll do
that so so you'll take way less up front
and you only take you know bank on your
shelves and take the ba back in and todd
phillips goes and todd feldman who's his
agent goes yeah we'll do that how about
this though and they go okay
it made
all the money all the money they made
and they changed hollywood forever
it's like in the history books for
agents there's a book on like caa and w
that that deal there changed the game
forever todd phillips todd filmer and
legends down yeah you tell you say todd
fell in his name around other agents
like oh the guy who did the
again because the studios were like
[ __ ]
over on us so yeah they bet on
themselves so todd when i was shooting
the hangover i looked at him because i
know him pretty damn well i looked at
him and i go i was making two grand for
the for the movie for that day yeah it's
two thousand daily rate yeah yeah and i
look at him and i go what are you making
for this because i know i had an idea of
what i'm the joker yeah no no no on uh
hangover oh yes i knew back then what he
was making it was a lot like what are
you making something i said something
like that and he goes
you're making more than i am right now i
go what he goes
i'm banking on getting back in and i
remember i've told the story before i
remember going you crazy [ __ ]
you got a bunch of non stars in this
movie nobody knows anybody here nobody
nobody knew bradley cooper or zack
galifianakis or did nobody do any of
them and i'm like you're doing this
movie with no names and you're you're
going to get it back i remember thinking
to myself dude i mean thank god you can
afford to take a hit that's what i said
and then
things my god things went kind of well
yeah yeah it was kind of wrong you could
never make another move again be all set
that's right and they're great yeah it's
beautiful but he hollywood said we will
never do that
i tried to get some color on joker too i
talked to him recently and i go uh
because i wanted to do something for me
but he couldn't because he was in he was
in a certain place scouting locations
for a joke or two and i go uh i go can i
get i asked him there's a couple rumors
and i asked him and he just went
don't you worry about anything
it's going to be epic does that mean is
he going to put you in it you think
i don't know it'll be cool i don't know
if daddy is uh i don't know if daddy's
going to get a
lead in the club yeah i think daddy's
just done with hollywood forever
uh todd phillips all based on yeah tough
phillips our boy though i am all based
on here sam
yeah don't think that brian i appreciate
it buddy no no i i honestly think this
is like a weird the whole woke thing
whatever
there's zero things about you that it's
true you know so it's like it's it's
gonna pass all this stuff dude in 15
years when you're 75
no sooner or later sooner than that i
love you i really don't i really do
believe that yeah well i know who i am
yeah we know who you are yep so just
keep being a better person
that's all
those guys did it though
they did it
they did it hey thanks for that that's
really interesting actually oh by the
way did you see the [ __ ] uh the fact
that they are really coming close to not
only curing baldness but reversing
baldness you know i saw that and you
know what i skim right by it well
because you don't care well it doesn't
affect me you know what i'm saying well
it affects everybody because actually
they're what the stem cell research
they're doing will help to cure wounds
and all kinds of crazies oh no that
stuff's cool i'm just saying for the
baldness
i passed right by at night i figured i
went should i send spring i'll see it
you should pass by it though because you
know what they said someday and someday
oh is way too far away all right that
does nothing for me some days too far
away
at least they're working on it i know
i'm looking at the mechanism of action
so it's it's just a single chemical is
key to controlling when hair follicle
cells divide and when they die because
that's really what you're trying to do
is keep these follicles from dying tgf
beta
you ever see david beckham in person oh
yeah he's such a dime piece oh my god
gorgeous sorry
sorry but he uh
um but isn't baldness predicated off
your was it your mom's side your mom's
grandpa
science yeah i think that's bro i don't
know but it might be bro science like in
other words they don't i i think it yes
it is irritable yeah but then look at
you and jay you have a full thick head
of hair j's
not the thickest head hair yeah you have
same parents name everything so
you know like when people are daredevils
versus really cautious they they think
that is a chemical in the brain and they
can up or lower that that dosage and you
end up being a little braver from what i
understand so so much of this [ __ ] is
how you're wired like if i was losing
hair
one i mean those guys like you know
pivot and
some other guys have fixed it machine
gun kelly i don't know if they're
wearing hair pieces or what you got
implants for implants mgk yeah you can
see before and then plants stay i guess
but so obviously implants the way to go
now with technology but also i look at
guys like trump or you know [ __ ] some
of these other guys
like lebron no they do give a [ __ ] and
they have all the money in the world
and they can't get it done
yeah well what do you do maybe because
lebron doesn't care though oh he can't
he does that yeah because he's trying to
he painted it
yeah he's tried everything
sometimes these mechanisms like for
example microdermabrasion like if you do
it the right way now it's a do you want
to have your scalp bleeding times a week
hold on
hold on
bro science alert yeah would you get
your degree in dermatology sir
no i mean i look at this stuff all the
time on youtube i don't i can't say that
i'm an expert on it but what i'm saying
is when i think about that options
it's hair transplant if you have money
that's the easiest thing but there's
much more to it you know even taking
finasteride every day or putting putting
uh anti-androgen it's still a routine
that you have to like do rich guys want
to be like oh i'm doing my nightly
one-hour hair routine yeah but you can
restore it it's just
a lot of the stuff i've read that's the
most effective it takes two hours a day
you know
put oils on your heads and take
chemicals what's weird is you don't see
women really losing their hair they do
not they're not like they don't they
don't different kind of testosterone
yeah
that's what the hd male pattern versus
they get thinning hair
but they're they don't have the [ __ ]
bird's nest that's
i got great idea i got great news guys
are you gonna get a wig i got no even
better news than wig um i get to go back
back to invisalign square one
so six months yeah some new ones on
remember that six months that was a
waste of time because daddy didn't wear
them 22 hours a day how many hours did
you win
sometimes 20 did you miss two hours sure
21 hours
you don't wear them 22 hours bubba
you go back to square one so you
basically you wear them all at all times
unless you're eating that's right
and daddy didn't he took a couple days
here and there and when you do that you
forgot they say to you we have to go
back
to square one you can't move one tooth
gotta move all the teeth and you wasted
all your putting on the first tray yeah
so now we're gonna restart well now this
is this is one year all together because
i remember i went i did it last time
didn't pay attention i've done it again
i've always said that's why you need
metal braces they're retro you have no
you have no say in it
right and your teeth to be straight by
now you'd have them off guess what
guess how long it would take so with
these if i wear them religiously for for
four months right now 22 hours a day 22
hours a day i go right back to perfect
teeth
with steel braces it would take three
and a half years
that's artificial intelligence ladies
and gentlemen wow yep now let's get my
head going
my son he's six months old he needs a
helmet
because uh
el cody
was in the icu for a long time and when
you're lying on your head like that even
if you hold them their head gets all
flat it looks like a ground dweller from
behind okay
so they have to put bracelets in helmet
though uh ty i think tiger boss was uh
no they weren't helm that's one of her
close friends at home kids are cute
[ __ ] kids he's really cute yeah he
pushes one of his eyes down yeah they
look like little uh like 1940 football
players it's hilarious yeah they're
they're cute as [ __ ] in those habits
that's 23 hours a day yeah poor kids
sweaty yeah they just get used to it
eventually but you feel bad for them
yeah it's really true yeah that's not
bad there kids go through it all the
time here's that flat top in the back
though cut that flat top yeah got to get
that around just from laying yeah
chilling got around you out a little bit
poor kid yeah so cute but you know in
the summer just wearing a helmet like
you're in a motorcycle for your entire
life that's right you sleep in it that's
right not fine
think about it's just not really
sweaty kid man yeah yeah not good
not good it's not good but it'll be
worth it because they don't have it on
that long because they're they're
skeletons their skull's so soft
and just moves eventually they just take
it off yeah this part our kids are
sweating it out sucks would you ever you
ever do the the leash thing with again
you've seen parents with a leash i have
i understand it i've never done it but i
get it
if you have a kid that's super
hyperactive and runs toward danger
having a leash is not the worst thing in
the world
if it's long enough and it's a harness
yeah it's like a backpack i get it for a
mom with like so if a mom has two kids
three kids three kids yeah she's trying
to wrangle her boys yeah you're right
yeah safety better to be safe
oh let me see what's going on okay we'll
keep talking oh with brittany griner
yeah what what um
yeah
yeah they're proposing a deal i guess uh
the
administration has proposed returning
convicted arms merchant victor baut to
russia merchant of death yeah he was the
guy they did the god of war or something
he was the guy who was an arms dealer
right
yeah oh lord of war
yeah
whoa twenty-five people i'm serving 25
years in u.s prison after he was
convicted in 2011 of conspiracy to kill
americans providing aid to the terrorist
organizations and other charges
terrible guy huh yeah that's him with a
mustache like that
in russia they keep you in a cage in
court
that picture right there
that's her in court not in jail
yeah um rogan had a good point too you
know
everyone's be they're all upset about
brittany grinder stuff like that being
held in russia for these marijuana
charges stuff like that rogan's like you
know how many people have an american
prisons
on literally they've been in there for
how long for marijuana charges
like you pick your poison like same
issue you're gonna be upset about that
and then yeah they're like you know
lebron said this he's like if i'm
brittany grant i don't want to come back
to america after my country treats me
like this it's like okay don't come back
here but also
there's people
in concert like they're incarcerated in
prison right now for years and they'll
have because they're not famous
basketball players have no hopes in
getting out unless like the kardashians
bring [ __ ] light to it you know what
i'm saying yes
yes like be upset about that too correct
that's just because she's good at
basketball people doing life sentences
but she's in russia making me tougher a
little different do we know what's going
on at the russians because the russians
are notoriously lenient
they're gonna let her out
they're just yeah but they're for their
for them it's a chess it's a political
like we'll let her out let the lord of
war out yeah
the lord of war who i believe in the our
government lord of war we're not [ __ ]
letting the lord of war out like all
right no deal [ __ ] killed americans
and lord hated terrorists his name's
lord of war she's a basketball player
like no we know this is the only chance
we have to get him out how long is she
looking at i'm behind bars
15 years something yeah like 10 15.
something like that
holy [ __ ] for smuggling marijuana in or
something
yeah yeah remember too
you like you know you can't do that in
those countries but you know she was
playing
you know you you think russians give a
[ __ ] about women's basketball ten years
in prison yeah
you know what i'm saying like think
about it so she goes over to russia to
play basketball these old guards have
those teams there and they pay them a
lot of money over there russians aren't
going to the games
women's games in russia we don't give a
[ __ ] here in america russia there's
seven people not it correct so those
older guards are just whenever you know
i don't know it's money laundering what
the [ __ ] they're doing so she's making a
lot of money to play over in russia all
the girls do they make more money
playing over there than in the states
but when she's going over there remember
her i bet she has the oligarch cell
phone yep and he was like yep when you
go through customs i'll handle it i'll
have you on the list well russia goes to
war with ukraine and we and all the
oligarchs are us as well like they're
going after the oligarchs like
[ __ ] he's riding a yacht and
fiji trying to you know whether he's
going parties yeah and he's a you know
like uh mr oligar one of the [ __ ] his
name is uh brittany greiner is like yeah
she
they took she had a marijuana pin he's
like what do you want me to do i have no
power now she's a pawn in a geopolitical
game 100 i hate that the first question
is how long is britney griner's face i
hate that that's the first question
i've never wondered how long her face is
i actually think she's quite
pretty
yeah this is strange you're brave for
saying oh i think it's just miss
how long does she face yeah i think
that's how long he's breaking great
yeah i think that's what was dude
just like this
but right under that result
yeah she's a cool looking human being in
general just a cool looking kind of how
tall is she six ten
two tall you know yeah two dollars being
prison
six nine that's unbelievable
yeah that that russian prison can't i
mean it can be a worse place to be
[ __ ]
in prison
is that his her girlfriend yeah wife
smashes that huh
wow
she is
people like people like if it's steph
curry he'd be back right now
yeah
hey yeah yeah the mvp
yeah he'd be in that prison for
literally 30 minutes remember the 90s
the caning the black people remember
that guy did graffiti an american kid it
was a big story he spot gum out or
something right something that might
have been because you can obviously get
executed for gum and you know singapore
but specifically this kid went to uh i
believe it was singapore could be wrong
um
but he
did graffiti and they came them it was a
huge deal to get you know so lee kuan
yew
who is a long time dictator and one
would say as close to a benevolent
dictator as it gets lee kuan yew
was i think he he was educated in oxford
he was a highly
highly intelligent educated man who took
over singapore right and he said okay
singapore i am in the golden triangle
i'm i'm i'm surrounded by the the
countries that make all the opium all
the heroin so he goes here's what's
going to happen guys if you're caught
bringing drugs any drugs in the
singapore you hang no jury just a judge
you hang
and every year they would hang about
five to seven people including tourists
including two canadians there was no
exceptions you got hung yeah
and they said well you hang them and you
don't get a trial he goes yes we hang
about we hang about five people a year
the americans um and we have zero drug
problems
how many people do you have in jail and
how many families are broken apart and
how many kids are in foster care because
of of drugs and alcohol and how much
damage is done every year you tell me
yeah i'll wait yup and it was such a
good argument it was like wow and then
so but lee kuan yew is famous for saying
no bell-bottoms you can't have long hair
and no chewing gum on the street now
that's draconian but man i've been to
singapore twice it's nice huh oh
it was it was the most modern most
beautiful place you've ever been to like
the oh the markets i mean it's one of
the best places in the world to live
it's basically all chinese
and foreign
it's far from a job offer i'd have to go
there twice a month are you okay you
know
i've never been there oh you haven't got
from the job moment let me look how long
the flights are oh you can't do it it's
too far about two more bucks
they do public housing differently like
instead of like we're going to put all
these people in a shitty area in the
ghetto right they go we're going to
match you up we're going to put all
these people into nicer neighborhoods
you're kind of like integrated piece by
piece to make up like you go what is the
racial um
makeup of the entire country and we're
going to say we're going to recreate
that so there's a little mix everywhere
and we're not going like all this race
is ghettoizing my only my caveat with
that would be in america we're dealing
with so many more people right like
that's such a small sample size so it's
going to be easier to do that stuff here
yeah you're dealing with tons and tons
of things right so it's a huge part of
it
directly
when i learned a lot listening to him a
huge part of the chinese
and maybe even asian but certainly
chinese mindset and and ethos and
philosophy and mythology is built around
harmony the idea of relationships your
relationship to the world around you and
so it's very very ingrained in when he
was talking about the idea of the reason
you won't have a homeless person on the
street
is it throws off the harmony of the
entire so you you get those people and
you put them somewhere where they can
get help or cleaned up or whatever it is
but you don't let them on the street it
throws off the general harmony the sort
of
what is it called what's that feng shui
yeah the feng shui of i mean
basically he [ __ ] up
feng shui
for money and [ __ ] [ __ ] up the vibe
talking about getting yang bro i think
yeah so what happened to daoist so what
happens
if you're homeless in singapore and
you're like i'm just gonna set up shop
on the street here okay so just beat you
with a canelo if you're homeless in
singapore
for real
a paddy wagon comes up
and takes you
and puts you in that paddy wagon and
they take you to a hospital they take
you there's a whole series of facilities
wow that basically get you cleaned up
and get you the help you need in one way
or another
yeah fun overnight shelters for those
that are unable to support themselves
and limit our necessity there are 11
welfare homes in singapore interesting
again smaller sample size but makes
sense
yeah but there is no homelessness i
don't know if it's changed but when i
was there
can you if i'm a homeless student i'm
trying to get there right trying to
collect enough money to get that
17-hour flight one way thicker yeah but
they it is do you see that arc on that
that american kid so he um
spit gum on the street but then they
also found he uh stole several street
signs
and they're going to give them 10 months
in prison and six slashings but they
change it to just six slashings a good
old canning
yeah can i speak to it yeah we saw a
video and it's like
oh is it bad
i'd rather have the caning than the ten
months in prison for sure all day it was
a hard like they can break skin on the
second one or whatever and right
rightfully so can you imagine if if we
did it here like it's a little pat
they're gonna keep stealing and spitting
up yeah but you imagine we're canaan
people here
yeah man i'd like to see uh six strokes
of the cane we see that video chin
anything
i'm so like oh that was the guy yeah it
came up yeah but guess what they would
give examples to like my recollection of
his they showed a guy who does the
canyon like doing it against uh um a
heavy bag or something you saw the force
with which he would hit the guy maybe
not the actual caning but
i like how they made a big holy [ __ ]
dude muslim woman is kane 23 times in
indonesia for standing too close to her
boyfriend
yeah well you're always going to have
insanity you know um world star there's
just all the time it's in india i guess
you can't show affection in public and
this dude they're like in a lake or
river or something like that everyone
you know all these indian dudes around
and the girls you know you know the
rules guys you know the rules the girls
straddling him in the water you know
he's holding the waters there she's not
a big girl and he's just holding her
like this and he kisses her and one of
the guys sees hey
dude bro it is
game on it is bully beat down they just
all rush over the water it's probably a
crowd of 30. just slap him in the face
slapping the heads up and he's like and
she's crying he's like trying to get out
of the water and they fall all the way
up and beat the [ __ ] out of him yeah
didn't like kill him but man it was like
a gang slapping or did they take turns
it sounds like they line up and
something oh
yeah that that awful mob mentality
happens on social media but not
physically
nuts
like 30 30 people taking an open hand to
you you're gonna feel that it's gonna
leave a mark oh you're not kissing a
girl in the pool anymore yeah doing that
right now yeah you're not doing that but
yeah i wonder how many prisoners here if
we're like
here's the thing
you served three years in uh la prison
or
uh
mark harley has a cane over there and
he's gonna slap you ten times set free
yeah if you get caught again it's 30
candles you caught again it's 60.
praying against about 60. but you know
i'm saying well saudi arabia has
floggings you get flog what's a vlog a
flogging is when you get
whipped sir uh whipped can you say
if you if you if you steal
you will have your right hand cut off
why right hand entire hand why right
hand versus left why shake it because
you shake hands with your right hand you
do your dirty stuff with your left hand
okay well yeah yeah so now you
traditionally when you got your left
your right hand cut off you had to wait
because everybody would eat like you'd
put the rice and the goat in the middle
everybody would sit and eat with their
right hand
nobody would touch with their left hand
but if you have no right hand you have
to wait till everybody else is done
eating and then you get to oh so they
just chop it off then you go to the
hospital so the yes so the same hand you
use for your wiping and your cleaning
and all that is what you used to eat it
was double punishment so nobody stole
the lowest crime rate in the world world
oh and by the way that's tough on crime
here like you're flogging people now
from flogging yeah and maybe that's a
fog horn is when you fart in somebody's
mouth and he goes
it's fog that's poghorning oh yeah
because the flogging flogging a
punishment fixed on this repeatedly with
a whip or a stick
now and i'll flog you if i want okay
okay you can vlog me i'm a fog horn i'll
flog the [ __ ] out i'll change your flog
for a foghorn i'll take a bullwhip and
i'll flog the [ __ ] out of you how's that
sound i'm in yeah
dude i'd much prefer that than get any
amount of time in prison slap me dude
in the face with that [ __ ] whip just
don't hit me in the eye now ask me what
the punishment for if you kill someone
or if you uh bring drugs into the castle
get your head off you get your head
severed from your body sir
you get your head leaves your body hold
on is that currently the situation yes
it is sir and i and i have another
caveat to add to that it's done publicly
in what americans call chop chop square
i believe it's done every friday
and apparently brian yes sir you are you
are marched out you are forced to squat
with your hands tied behind your back
as someone reads verses of the quran
and then they they touch you they stab
you a little in the in the in the side
so your body tenses up yeah you go like
that and then the guy goes touch boom
and then your head comes off now let me
ask you this are they struggling the
same things we are are they concerned
about their pronoun they're not they're
not like before they chop your head off
you're like just let everybody know my
pronouns are he and she yeah no you
don't even have to lock your doors when
we lived there we didn't lock our doors
once there's just been a crime
there ain't no crime well think of dude
if
if you're cutting people's hands off for
stealing yeah that person that's
stealing boy
you're really going to think twice you
got that if if it was the group of the
four of us were in a car and we lived
where is this they couldn't start
was like hey fellas you want to go in
and steal some video games and you were
like
we can
we're on vacation right now i play the
piano and i just want you to know
if we get cotton there's a chance we
will they're going to cut off all our
hands what do you mean like just your
hand no no whoever's involved we're
going to lose our right hand i go i'm
not going to steal no you're not
no no because nothing's worth that but
you know what you should do like uh
garcon does here
nothing
so there's they're two criminals they go
you're good too expensive get back out
there man
so you took a couple swings and you
missed get back out there
saudi arabia goes well you can go back
out but you can be missing a hand that's
right and that seems more
wise more wise
more wasn't they do it publicly just so
everybody understands the rules are it's
also like a scarlet letter
yeah like can you imagine if like let's
say you brought in some random dude like
you used to do like hey hey b this guy
thinks he can help a thick boy and i go
to shake his hand and just [ __ ] yeah
oh huh we're all good yeah no you don't
no i got it we're good do you understand
got your hand off you don't believe in
redemption sir
well tell you what come back when you
regrow that hand huh yeah you can't
really hide that that's the best part
about it yeah it's like uh in glorious
bastards the nazis when brad pitt when
they cut that the main guy and he goes
uh
so
what are you gonna do when you leave
here if we let you go are you gonna do
where you do this whole get up you got
the whole not the out videos i'm i'm
gonna burn i'm getting rid of you i
thought you'd say that and i don't like
that so they would take a knife and
carve in the
nazi sign into their forehead he goes
because you can't take that off yeah i
want everybody to know what a piece of
[ __ ] you were such a good movie same
with some people's hands off like you
can't handle if it wasn't
you know
now that is you don't believe in
redemption
redem
i believe redemption hey i'll flog you
shut up yeah flogging is fine
here's what's gonna happen when the show
ends right vlogging cool i'm going to
foghorn your stupid mouth where is
poghorn what are you doing i fart in
your mouth and then through your nose he
goes
with your stupid new invisible line
that's clearly enough wait do you push
your butthole do you hold
it like this
i hold you hard so yeah you [ __ ] me up
then you sit and you go yeah i don't
want that far getting anywhere yeah and
i told you before i came here i said b
i didn't eat a single ounce of food
yesterday yeah i did two sets last night
around hollywood at midnight i went well
papa's gonna pass out i'm dizzy i need
food the only thing opens fast food so
we have fast food the first time in a
hot second
i drove by a taco bell and the last time
we had taco bell dude those loco dorito
tacos were the shells made out of a
dorito sir turn in the tube that's
america turn you in a toot machine
that's america yeah so i got three of
those right
diet dr pepper gotta keep it somewhat
healthy of course and i wash that all
down with a chicken quesadilla with red
sauce now i drove with my knees while i
put the sauce on i'm going 90 miles an
hour i put the sam
i eat all that right
felt fantastic i felt bad afterwards but
while i was eating it
top 10 best moments of my life delicious
driving my knees at
right and then i uh
he kicked in
you boy can't stop farting yeah yeah
taco bell i don't know what's in there
this morning too that mystery meat that
mystery meal you'll take four or five
shits well beef doesn't look like that
right tastes delicious but that is clay
that is a clay beef that they put a ton
of sodium flavoring in and it's
fantastic and i think silicone or
something in there who knows
hey who look at the meat and taco bell
it's really interesting now let me ask
you this oh but farting oh my my my son
today dad please stop farting yeah
yeah
okay 88
quality usda inspected beef 12 percent
seasoning spicy watermelon okay the
thing that's uh alarming on those other
ingredients yeah let's see is that well
made of [ __ ]
uh
i compare it much the same way for
talking at home
all right all right okay
do you know who's [ __ ] this a subway
remember when it came out like they they
just randomly picked a store and
investigated the tuna it was just fake
tuna and they just got blasted and had
to come out like no it's real tuna no
that same
like investigators went oh it is oh yeah
we just made a mistake
we're not going to tell you we're
shooting another random one not in the
same city we're going to just around one
we're in new jersey we're going to fly
to l.a and check the subway tuna there
because we probably made a mistake
tilapia no if we go fish we'd celebrate
it was we don't know what it was
dude they're like we
it's not even showing up on our system
whoa this [ __ ] is fingerprints
it's fingernails and mayonnaise
ordered tuna from subway
and i've never in my life now i love
that a good tuna melt oh yeah nice right
longer he uses wild coffee
but the the tuna always looks suspect to
me at subway
has anyone taken a bigger fall
than subway because remember they were
popping when i was younger oh yeah
there's blimpies in colorado shout out
to blimp he's always better than subway
way fresher yeah and then subway right
crashing it foot longs up five five
dollar foot long
and then and then your boy
your boy whose name slips like a jig
yeah jerry from subway goes i only ate
subs for six years i've lost 300 pounds
you're our mascot yeah and then they're
slaying us up slang
subs and all of a sudden
jared
likes
young boys touches kids he's in prison
great for life young girls girls oh
girls yeah yeah real either way
frownable
yeah little kids like six-year-old seven
then he blamed it on the sub yeah yeah
so he was sub crazy caught caught saying
uh you gotta get kids that come from
broken homes
terrible person great you don't feel one
on a date with his sister really didn't
know it yeah well she threw it in there
his sister shouldn't be allowed to be uh
well she's just i mean his sister
shouldn't be lumped in with him she's
her own person well no but think about
she was trying to flex on theo at the
time she and bit this was before he got
convicted he had no idea
no idea you know whatever when i he was
never really a much of a celebrity he
was always oh he's here he was
everywhere though yeah
five five dollar foot long
business
papa john's papa john's yeah but they're
they're both doing pretty well still
aren't they yeah subway yeah i don't
know
i have no clue i don't know where one's
at
they're all over the place
i wouldn't eat it like if let's say mark
came in tomorrow or on saturday's
fighting man if you came here like hey
guys i got [ __ ] foot longs on subway
i wouldn't touch it yeah i never that's
how the marketing has gone for them
private oh
okay um
what was interesting hearing you know
obviously different fast food franchises
have different policies of even how you
get to be a franchisee like in and out
super selective right
subway has some issues apparently it's
been a 22 percent in decrease whoa over
the past year two years alone that's
huge subway lost more than 1 000 u.s
locations last year
so they kind of don't support the
franchisees they're kind of like yeah
yeah you can open one good luck you know
so everyone's like in and out vet you to
the max and then yeah like i know
mcdonald's like there's a franchise fee
right i know mcdonald's like a million
bucks just to have their franchise
mcdonald's yeah
starbucks is another really high-priced
one you can franchise it depend on the
area and how many are in the
radius there's like some weird thing
they do yeah but all like starbucks and
uh mcdonald's look it up chen pretty
sure like what's the most expensive uh
fast food restaurants to franchise
pretty sure mcdonald's is up
i've never seen mcdonald's not pop
i would do chick-fil-a yeah oh yeah and
then be open on sunday i bet those two
are the problem in and out and
chick-fil-a probably the most selective
where they're like prove to us that
you're this hyper reliable person you
know with the best finances and then
yeah
to open out
it says culver's
uh
so if you click down uh there yeah click
on that starbucks 2020. well that's just
the most valuable see subway's still at
uh
eight billion
to open i'll just put
amazing how they build something like
that
one of the most expensive franchises in
the uh in my doubletree hotel which can
cost over 50 million to get started yeah
because you're buying a giant piece of
[ __ ] property uh restaurant
franchises casual restaurants like tga
fridays
a million bucks that's a surprise
danny's cost between one to two million
interesting uh hilton though i mean
yeah and to get your money back you're
gonna have to really oh
you're gonna have to hustle i've looked
at those numbers my father my
ex-father-in-law was up on that stuff
you want to open one you do it right you
make some money if you own three
and it's in a good area you can make up
to a million dollars a year oh you're
balling yeah
uh the many of the base burger king and
uh mcdonald's charges a higher franchise
fee
yeah though
those storage setters are gonna store
which is so weird but yeah what is what
storage storage stores yeah my uncle had
a bunch of storage ones back in the day
yeah good business you got low
maintenance yeah you have some on the
property and then also if you don't pay
like you're just like cool we're
auctioning your stuff versus trying to
get you cool
i'm going to be on a [ __ ] you know on
that store whatever is pickers yeah yeah
i'm gonna invite them and go through
your [ __ ] dude yeah
yeah i like i was i was getting into
business with this hot chicken company i
won't say who it is it was my favorite
hot chicken at the time
we're going through the numbers they
want to put cash up you know it's tough
the break even it's tough yeah
and then the marketing's on you know
gyms gyms and restaurants like actual
restaurants yeah with like a chef so
hard the worst so hard to make money
gyms say four years if you're
killing it crushing it to break even yes
that's crazy
nah not for me not for me well i'd open
a cinnabon
we just do cinnabuns not all this fancy
[ __ ] just the original cinnabon i mean
they're so good we only have one they're
so delicious i think if we had one in
this office can you eat a whole one
they're so sweet
yeah
you know what they do now my favorite
part as a kid you can get just the
middles
you see all that [ __ ] on the outside
the heart crunching are you just trying
to get that gooey center
dude
brilliant marking someone's like listen
we all hate the crust on the outside
that crunchy [ __ ]
why don't we just make middles
i went to a restaurant it's like yeah
dude the side episode muffin tops
isn't this
[Laughter]
i went to a [ __ ] restaurant that some
always has great food it's called the
strand house it's in manhattan beach
it's one of the best
and i [ __ ] we have this crazy meal
and then what do they bring out they
bring out
donuts yeah
donuts are always they were hot they
were [ __ ] hot don't show me bad if
you go stale and they were about that
big but they were so [ __ ] delicious
so you could eat well i ate them all
what's a donut though yeah it's a
doughnut but it's not a huge one yeah
they're they're always amazing chocolate
chip cookies and donuts forget it
even i think it's united if you fly
united lady i think i don't know if they
in first class they give you it's like a
muffin chocolate chip cookie yeah i mean
jay we're talking about this i told jay
the cheat code i go dude they have so
many of those they're too small for us
right always ask for extras they have so
many extras and uh jiggles you're right
i ate four of them
jesus christ you asked for four he'll
take some candy down yeah
he'll take candy down he keeps still
smashing the candy yeah yeah yeah
candyman all right chin what do you got
all right
let's start with some of the marks real
quick
mark good posture hey thanks
very much check out the new thick boy
trunks he's wearing not bad huh
good model
pants no so um
this guy zach wilson you know exactly
wilson's fellas now let me get a
background for you
zack wilson was a very uh he was a
first-round draft pick high draft pick
for the new york jets
this why this story is interesting is
zach wilson played for byu was a damn
good college football quarterback
uh but grew up mormon very strict mormon
carry on mark this gets interesting oh
yeah so turns out his
girlfriend accused him of sleeping with
his mom's best friend and i'm glad i
sorted out that sentence because in my
head earlier it was like he slept with
the girlfriend's best friend or
girlfriend's mom no mom's best he's a
mom's best friend so he's questioning
his mom's best friend yeah i mean this
these things can happen
yeah the heart wants what the heart
wants okay
so there's this girl bona fide diamond
that's it that's a handsome he said not
good enough she's a [ __ ] so he was he
slept with mom's best friend while he
was with that girl here's the other
thing here's what's weird the more you
look into it his promise senior year in
high school he went to prom with two
older women
interesting two of them he like
shot older women by the way older women
meaning his mom his mom's friend's
probably 40 and a dime piece let's find
out
how many images yep there's images so
he's questioned about it it says when i
make a mistake
uh i can correct myself now
i feel like i keep improving and getting
better just the understanding of what
i'm asked to do in this office
now sometimes those interceptions are 40
year old mills yeah i'm trying to throw
a touchdown how do you get caught doing
it
good question
they found him in that milf sucking face
of the subway
uh
wait how so come on like wilson
he was caught on camera with a mystery
woman during the top of the show look at
his girlfriend though i mean
what but bring up the the mystery milf
and his mom's
i guess
it was at a yankees game
wait he was sucking face with her a
yankees game come on zack wilson yeah
is that her no that's his girl
his girl is
painfully hot
then look at his mama though
you see his mama
uh-huh she looks crazy mom's best friend
photos oh that's her there is that her i
don't know that's just a bad picture up
here though she's very upset there she
looks like a karen right there she's
she's probably hot
i can't see it that's just a bad picture
and you can see the hotness yep you can
see it
young guy one thing leads to another
but that's his girl though that's like
this girl what the hell the heck no it's
fun it's real fun you know it feels
great i'm sure unreal right but
you know
sometimes you want to try that vintage
wine baby
i understand but it's true is this a
rumor or is it true is what i'm saying
um man
i mean
his mom went pretty hard on social media
too how upset people were so i don't
know
that's her there
i don't know we'll see
okay and then if you're that young kid
you're like god damn it
hot friends surfaces
i mean that looks like that's i saw this
friends are freaking amazing that's his
mom calling my friends oh that's his mom
okay so that was a mom yeah i remember
this
i saw he was so stupid
is that her oh my god look at his friend
so i guess guile accused him on social
media
um
uh
which friend you talking about because
somebody some people what do you mean
they're all giant the the one the one
that said i know you and quagmire had a
baby that's a big boy right there yeah
dude his jaw is
his head looks photoshopped
oh that kid yeah what do you mean oh
that kid get off the guy's nuts on the
left because he's big left guy dude look
at this [ __ ] mullet that's the
craziest like jaw it's insane
mandibles yes mandibles yeah it's nuts
dude you'd eat those jacks these kids
all playing on the jets or is it just
so i guess on social media his
ex-girlfriend revealed she's now dating
washington commander's receiver dax mill
is that his name who roomed with wilson
during their days at at byu little
people back at him leading to her being
called a homie hopper by somebody well
bring him up and somebody says wilson
wilson was sleeping with his mom's best
friend that's the real homie hopper guy
who responded to one critic on history
so a lot of [ __ ] going on a lot of
[ __ ] going on your girlfriend said
that's a real homie hopper what's his
name dax wilson um his name is dax milne
d-a-x-m-i-l-n-e
sounds like the old lady and the and the
girlfriend are both homey hoppers also
what a great name
i thought it was gonna be a i thought
it's gonna be a
black dude to be honest well yeah well
that's right that's not racist is the
name receiver that's that's a kid
i mean yeah white guy from byu wow there
you go all right he's good hands
he's got great hands and i should have
known
he's byu
uh did he call everyone like i can't
believe this happened to you why don't
you uh
yeah
we should talk the old homie hopper yeah
no you are brian you're a homie hopper
but if you get the homie hopper pass for
just 20 more wow that's amazing
homie hopper i don't know what to say
about her great name
homie hopper oh say it again homie
hopper they say it ain't no fun if the
homies can't get none so yeah nate dog
did say that
well
he lost that dime piece and she went to
that guy yeah yeah hey look at me though
starting quebec for the jets
yeah you think so are you you know
excited you don't think new york likes
you know walking around in new york city
and if he starts winning football games
do you think like no means nobody likes
mark sanchez at all yeah yeah he's not
you start winning football games he's
not gorgeous or anything yeah and smart
he's a great guy how's he doing have you
talked to him not a little bit but i'm
sure he's doing well great you're a
homie hopper what else you got jim
um another one of mark's
yeah um
oh we definitely can't show this though
oh we're not gonna show it yeah okay
show it to us
right if you just show like a crane
um oh i thought you'd actually see
something
wait hold on
the rising tick tock star died during a
free gas we kept by horrifying the shows
so is she so he or she is below this
grain
there is she piloting it so she's a
crane operator i guess in russia
was usually trained to load concrete uh
major oil hub in siberia
uh a gust of wind had reportedly blown
the structure over causing the cabin to
topple 40 feet to the ground killing the
single mother of two on impact
wow so it looks like she's was that her
hanging from that rope or was she just
no she i think she did the thing okay
tic toc star
forty thousand followers yeah people use
this throw around the term like tick
talker youtuber it's like okay okay
what's this well
lady who's on tick tock you know where
you can just say this just an accident
yeah lady dies and i'll say random
accident like social media yeah yeah
but i guess we all fell folks like
always a famous person yeah i mean it's
all due respect to the dead but that
that's what happens yeah like if i die
riding my road bike i pray to god the
headlines that like avid bicyclists
brendan shop dies on
i like i enjoy riding bikes yeah one of
many things i do yeah i prefer different
headlines and then just he was kind
sympathetic
and generous tick tock star brennan job
don
enthusiast you know what i'm gonna say
homie hopper i'm gonna go like this i'm
gonna go no i'm gonna go he called it he
didn't expect to live long he's huge
yeah that's fine
we didn't think he got like this thought
his old ticker was going to go any day
now but this is probably better you're
you're ready to die in seven and then at
the end and then at the end you just go
he was always a homie hopper little
homie hopper
a little homie hopper this kid you know
this might it's gonna ruin the funeral
you go it's gonna make him laugh up in
heaven but
hope hop
hope the hop the homies up there you
know
nobody'll know what i'm talking about
we will and then i'll go like this you
gotta listen to the podcast guys it's an
inside joke but you know what all that
matters
he gets it yep
auditioning sidekicks guys
i need a new robin
i need a new robin to my batman
and marco's here no not you anybody else
i just totally don't even listen to him
i go anyone anyone who's like here
what else got jen all right so
i know you hate this brennan but so
there are reports that conor mcgregor
versus floyd miller two is gonna happen
and there's a little bit of a
stipulation
uh
they're negotiating over terms
um conor wants it to be an actual fight
that's get that gets on their record a
boxing fight
and 10 rounds versus 12.
oh
yeah
i just can go it's going to do nowhere
near what it was so when they asked dana
about it he goes i have less than zero
interest and see that again
because mcgregor's next fight will be
allowed to get unlocked again octagon
potentially against lightweight
contender michael chandler come on my
boy chandler we just dropped the food
truck
he talks about it
i'm super excited about javonte davis
and ryan garcia is that going to happen
that's a test for ryan garcia oh big
time that's going to be it's nothing
official that's what ryan garcia wants i
know he won't yeah okay
wow that would be crazy i'm with daniel
i have no interest in this especially
they're older like it's just but that
undercard i don't think that sells at
all
not nearly as much as it saw the first
time yeah sure nowhere near because
we've seen like the cat like we've seen
how the magic works yeah like we're like
okay we gotta peek behind the curtain
like we're not getting our money again
oh it's also at 155 so conor has to drop
weight which is going to be tough
it'll make money but it won't do like
gangbusters like you did not tell us
yeah he's big now but he's you know he's
trying to get back oh this is so crazy
you saw this brian yeah okay so this is
a
a road rage incident and the reason why
this is kind of crazy because the girl
is like super bodied up and i'll just
show you the video it's all so crazy
because
yeah they had a oh they had a baby in
the back seat as well i guess this guy's
an ex-military guy as well hold up they
both have guns no no she does
she's the one that shot at the
other driver
so let me uh wait real quick
holy sh is she out of her mind
it's a road rage thing so you know like
when you're like no no i don't i don't
no absolutely don't no i wouldn't yeah
no one here would ever shoot at somebody
but i'm saying like it's a road rage
thing so
she's out of her freaking mind i have no
idea what happened what if what if that
person was shooting at her you know like
we don't know
uh
right he's going to shoot jake no he
actually tries to pull her away that's
it big time jail right there oh no no so
she said you were trying to get away and
you shot at that car oh yeah big time
yeah [ __ ] and over what because he cut
you off we have no idea what happened
wow
yeah but she had a two-year-old they had
a two-year-old
insane dude
she is [ __ ]
and that's her
she's pretty yeah pretty girl and that's
the dude that's the military so the yeah
the car that they're shooting at had a
two-year-old oh my god i thought it was
the third one
that's what i thought oh my god
oh there goes shooting out a vehicle
with a two-year-old inside that's
nuts-o's
jumping oh
this person filming got some balls with
lady with a guy i know right behind too
well hold on can you can i read that
what happened yeah so
the both vehicles came to stop gonzalez
agreement who was playing a navy veteran
exit his vehicle and approach the victim
and start assaulting him if the victim
tried to leave ortiz who was a passenger
in greensboro as they exited the car and
shot into the back seat window
the victim continued to drive and
gonzales said the woman fired a second
shot striking a nearby dealership
building in the video which was posted
on social media woman could have seen
fire two shots toward the v she's such a
dumb ass she's such a [ __ ] people
are such [ __ ] she's so lucky that
bulletin a hit the kid thank god
of course get somebody in the dealership
because you kill someone you wait for
life yeah so it's like not to mention
not to mention the [ __ ] uh guilt
associated with it you [ __ ]
you you know so the guy was actually
grazed but he's fine he was grazed that
was it dude but yes that's shot freaking
stuff he had a two-year-old in the car
you [ __ ] idiot
and then when somebody's driving away
like that and you shoot at them you're
so [ __ ] and should be anyway if
somebody's in your house and they have a
tv in their hand and you shoot them
you're [ __ ] if somebody's in your
house and they're walking away they're
trying to get out of your house and
shoot them in the back you're in deep
[ __ ]
because you you weren't under threat and
they were stealing your property and you
can't kill somebody for that
it depends
you don't want that you're gonna if you
get off it's gonna cost you half a
million dollars
though but if they
endanger your family like yeah you gotta
do you're in my house i'm gonna have a
problem with you i'm gonna shoot you but
i'm saying
um let's see here
no not that one this one okay this has
nothing to do with anything but this is
our emanuel
and he married this girl like a fashion
designer in may oh so i just are you
emanuel uh he that's who jeremy piven
character was based off of entourage yep
he's
yeah so they own the ufc who comes from
the ufc's
but i think so he married a girl that i
think looks like the facial features are
so similar jaws
their jaws are not just that dude hold
on their jaws are so long right yes that
and the noses too i think a lot of
things are those cheekbones they look
like brother and sister like she looks
like they're very much yeah these are
interesting to me
people do say like i guess
uh professionals that are looking at
facial features and and people that
connect with other people they say that
people have similar facial features are
attracted to the same you know the uh oh
he might saw that joel a mile away like
holy [ __ ] you know he could you know he
could dunk a basketball
really yeah kind of a random thing
my buddy my buddy um
travis told me that he [ __ ] was
dunking a a dunkin a basketball because
he was a a chef for um joel silver and
our emanuel came over and he was
not the nicest guy
but he uh he goes the [ __ ] guy is
like was i guess he played basketball in
college look that up he was duncan and i
think there's
how old is he
well now he's like but this is when he
was like 38 or something like that
it's kind of crazy
no i'm saying manual
yeah
it's like it was dunking i was like yeah
you sure he goes yeah dude it blew my
mind
my buddy is uh you know he knows the
difference i was like all right i still
don't buy it i see it though i don't
think you guys lied but i think it was
the eight foot rim yeah that could be
that's that's how tall is zarya manual
not let's start there not big
that's i'm going to tell you right now
the small juice guy duncan
oops okay
all right must be video of it right five
seven
that can't be real no no it's real i've
seen them in person
i was gonna say five eight hey look at
me what are you saying hey hey look at
me hey hey b
hey
hey homie hopper
you know your friends for the most part
your friends lie all full of [ __ ] right
right
and you know what works because all you
guys are oh my god that's crazy if i was
there i thought it was about
uh aries five that's about six two the
small juice guy has a
45 inch bird oh but you're lying right
right right that's how this should have
went right
was it arya manual
no don't try him yeah there was another
guy named emmanuel that was michael
jordan that's what he was talking about
michael jordan it was michael jordan or
maybe amari stottemeyer he's five seven
yeah small juice guy yeah
he's not five seven he's not talking to
right he didn't play college basketball
that never happened i do you know my
favorite girl i think you played college
basketball now here's the thing as soon
as you said that i went oh this never
happened well i told brennan i played
three on three it's coming out my best
of milwaukee i played three on three
with uh the marquette basketball team me
and my boy kevin mcnamara tall guy and
then my other buddy nick
simmons who's five seven and a
bodybuilder and we played against three
gentlemen uh from marquette basketball
d1 players oh so who is six
uh um
another guy named he's from
he's fi he's six nine and another guy
who's six five it didn't go well through
the three giant yeah it didn't go so
well with the three white guys let me
say this how how how
hard did their [ __ ] go down all three
of you well this part of them
this part of my head still smells like
the bottom of their balls it still
smells like they're under carriage and
this part of my head smells a lot like
they're giant
big tank they were jumping they were
[ __ ] with us and just dunking on us
and they were they were just
like it was a very interesting
experience to see what a real athlete
was and i think you told me if you
played for marquette your chances of
being in the nba
are slim to vanishing i said their
chances yeah i'm saying there's
because there's guys like uh
what's his name flash played from miami
dwayne dwyane wade came from marquette
yeah so i mean there's there's outliers
yeah but for the most part all those
amazing d1 athletes a small fraction to
the nba and i said to the coach i said
well one of the guys who works at i go
who's going to the nba and he all he
said was it's tough
it's very tough i go but this six foot
ten guy is not only 610 but fast as [ __ ]
and can hit from anywhere now here's the
thing the kid from duke who's 6 10 who's
light years better than anybody played
against probably have a tough time with
them it means mission impossible it's
mission impossible there's 12 guys on
teams
you're gonna have to take some veterans
job even if you're drafting the second
round you have a hard time making
something you know that's [ __ ] nuts
yeah yeah it's not 52 players on like in
the nfl it's
12. it's 12.
but but those d1 players and marquette
are so good i can't believe it
they're so strong so good so fast i
can't believe it i can't well what did
you think
i expected but i just
but there there's something about when
you see somebody who's tall and skinny
because they're tall and skinny you
don't think they're going to be that
fast that powerful that good it's just a
different thing and then you're up close
to it and you're like
i am a comedian i am not in any way an
athlete you know what i am i'm kind of
coordinated
pretty coordinated like i can i can
mimic something if you tell me hey bry
swing that golf club i don't look like a
complete idiot that's all i have here's
some athleticism i guess for 50 what are
you [ __ ] no but even when i was 20
yeah one i mean i i'm i'm a little
coordinated you know what i could have
danced i could have been a dancer not
the greatest answer but not a bad dancer
i believe that
we
have you seen the number one recruit for
the draft next year the number one draft
pick no i'd like to see it well he's
real nice i didn't want to go down there
take too long let me just explain left
bring it up because it also highlights
from doom justice but let me tell you
stats right okay these more cat counties
right you're like which one's going to
be cool so this kid's 17
they say he is the best prospect since
lebron james that worked out right
lebron went
[ __ ] good yeah because 17.
they believe
he's listed at 7-2
but they what they did is they have a
picture and he's saying that because he
played like this pro-league thing they
have him standing next to a 7-3 guy and
he's two inches taught him because being
tall isn't a good thing in the nba yeah
because it shows people that are players
over seven foot they always get injured
they don't have long careers like yao
ming and stuff like they're really good
for a short distance but there's no
longevity right so being too tall is
actually a hindrance to him sure but
they believe
that they're lying that he's 7-2 and
then they show proof a picture at this
like pro-am game next to the guy who's
7-3 and he's
well taller than him now he's 17 he's a
mixed kid right he's french but i think
african right so he's like good looking
kid
he
moves like [ __ ] dwyane wade they say
he's a combination of kevin durant shoot
so he's just
7-5
stroke in threes you can't no one's
gonna stop the [ __ ] shot dude
you can't stop his shot who are you
gonna do nothing his wingspan also seven
is his dad from the sudan
i don't know don't care that's why i
don't wanna go down this road
his ankles are this thing he has no
muscle on right now but yeah he can dude
handles so he's he's physical he's
he's no no would you would you type your
kids seven foot seventeen-year-old
basketball poor guy no no no no no i
mean seven seven is your moment
there it is
if you just type in change just type in
top prospect of nba draft two thousand
twenty
fifty type that in though hold on victor
i agree or you could google literally
everything we've been talking about
draft pick
this guy that guy
yeah aka victor
they think he's the best prospect to
come out yeah so he's 18 the best
prospect to come out in seven three
forever he's seven they say he's a mix
of porzingis and kevin durant which if
that is true
would be on
[ __ ] real
friends now it's tough to see how good
he is like you can tell you know shots
dope because yeah because when he's
playing against other high school kids
it's like all right you're seven five
who are the parents can i see that
please
go back i'm curious now who are the
parents no it's right there you can see
it down there
that is [ __ ] unreal
that is unreal to me man and he's but
he's saying he is he's got speed he's
got
all that stuff mm-hmm
hmm
his mother played basketball
[Music]
yeah he practiced judo was a goalkeeper
in football
okay
it's just his sister played pro
basketball too i mean just you know just
just a
family of crazy athletes he's seven
[ __ ] five dude
yeah that's remarkable
imagine being seven five i think granted
he's eighteen see seven five how does he
skin and he's 205 he's so skinny good
god he's skinny that's super skinny
strange right yeah
yeah that's a very skinny kid no clothes
look cool on you they just don't make
them for yourself seven five what car
you're gonna do you're not doing much
you're gonna be wealthy
so so there is so rudy goldberg is seven
one
okay okay
yeah that's
skinny his legs are now granted he's
eighteen put some meat on him he'll put
some meat on him
he'll be listening he's gonna be a
problem they say again i think he's too
tall he's gonna get injured but whatever
yeah he probably will right when you're
getting banged up a lot i mean strong
wayne would beat him up
yeah
what else you got jen but he will be in
the nba yeah i'll be the number one pick
right he'll be the number one pick have
you guys seen this viral video no but i
like seeing monkeys beat people up yeah
so this girl is taunting this monkey and
then i'll just show you the video
to a monkey
spider monkey
that's strong they're laughing and not
helping it nope
i mean if it was like a big chimpanzee i
get it but it's a little tiny monkey
and then
she walks past it again and gets her
hair pulled again
it's just so stuck
yeah well now i was having a good time
it looks like i saw one where the guy
was [ __ ] around with a tiger you know
yeah
yeah
you can't do that yeah i ripped this on
i keep hearing about the guy who lost
his pocket look at that have you seen
this bro yeah it's crazy okay so not
many likes but still this guy got a
tattoo of you three likes that's
impressive insulting thank you whoever
you are thank you i'll give them a
little bit flattered yeah give it a love
to get a tattoo yeah that's awesome they
gave you the good hair
they gave me the good hair i'd love to
have that hair i was when i was younger
yep i don't know what i was doing there
but i love it yep thank you sir
that works give us one more chin all
right this is it uh so this is lady gaga
i'll try to like mute the sound but so
apparently someone threw something at
her and then everyone's this this went
totally viral so some everyone's saying
there's like an invisible force or a
shield or whatever it probably is watch
[Music]
whoa you can barely see it though right
you can dance man just a dead you see it
yeah something gets thrown there but it
doesn't it stops knitter
it hits something
almost like dance look at her man
there's many molecules of air of course
she could dance dude the invisible
shield brian that's the problem you know
what it looks like bubba looks like a
trick no it looks like it's a trick it
looks like somebody threw it against the
tv
do you understand what i'm saying you
know what brian that's a damn good life
that's a damn good point it doesn't look
live it could be but then it's too big
watch it again but people on the bottom
that's the thing that's see the point
how big it is watch how big it is
look at this
the phones are down here they're not
going to air it with those cameras that
angles from a fan's point of view yeah
yeah they're not the phones are here
it's not there's an audience coming what
they throw that's the peak of uh
the trajectory and it comes down
no but it runs into something because
yeah you can see it's hitting literally
hits i'll tell you what it looks like
also it could have been it could be
thrown this way up and came down watch
no no brian clearly not something
[Music]
yeah nothing stops yeah stops
stops
yeah yeah so she has a star trek force
here okay
or
what i said that was just like a big
viral thing
that's pretty cool yeah
that can't be cheap invisible force
field and if lady gaga has that thing
what our military has
yeah
i'll tell you what i don't have a force
field but please don't throw things i
will be in baltimore next week thursday
friday saturday i'm in baltimore next
week thursday friday saturday this
saturday we have a very special fight
companion for ufc 277 we have crystalia
eric griffin and matt matrion and myself
all for the calabasas fight companion
but baby that's saturday at 7 pm pacific
live on think boy we just dropped our
newest food truck diaries with michael
chandler it's a tasty one and then
august 26 one show one night only 7 30.
den theater downtown chicago come get
you some because the next day on 27th we
have the chicago tough mudder you can
sign up it's the 10 a.m heat they just
released tickets you get 10 discount uh
when you use promo code team brendan
it's uh the thick boy team versus the
buttery bros so whoever has more signups
wins that one it's limited capacity so
make sure you get tickets at uh
toughmutter.com you'll see the thick
mudder sign up at 10 a.m on the 27th
then appleton wisconsin september 8th
through the 10th
ontario which that's in the at least i
don't have to travel for that one
ontario september 15th through the 17th
ontario improv and then boston laugh
boston is september 29th through october
1st but baltimore you're up next week
take us at thickboy.com and the merch
you'll see the commercials popping on
social media but um
the merch this shirt the thick shirt the
the thick hat the thick
shorts marks the tie-dye shorts we have
tie-dye shirts tie-dye hoodies
thickboy.com and that drops friday
morning at 9 00 a.m
beautiful
austin texas this weekend baby i'll see
you thursday friday saturday nashville
tennessee zany's august 26 27 san jose
california improv september 15 17 spakan
comedy club september 22-24
tacoma comedy club september 29th
october 1. wow i'm i am booked to the
guilds and i'm loving it it's good for
you man hashtag blessed
oh god god you're a homie hopper god i'm
a homie hopper
but for me in the homie hopper hashtag
bless hashtag we're so lucky you get to
do this oh my god get back
pay it forward thanks
god bless you let us stuff you yeah
we're out